let's talk about this story that you
guys have at the post millennial because
it's horrifying and probably get us in
trouble on youtube but we should talk
about it let's do it it didn't get the
high school in trouble on social media
so it'll get us in trouble for we'll get
in trouble we're talking about it yeah
oh it was it was on social media
from post millennial post-millennial
investigation underway after kentucky
high school hosts drag pageant featuring
male teens and lingerie giving lap
dances to staff oh my gosh i didn't
realize that people what dancing were
minors yes
i didn't know i'm serious i didn't i
when people were
sharing the story i was like oh that's
horrible and disgusting i didn't realize
that it wasn't like they brought people
in to do something inappropriate in a
high school they actually had minors
doing this
dude that's like they had that's like
yeah that should be hard time yeah those
are minors you're that you're having
give lap dances yeah there are uh that's
a sex offense absolute state of these
united states what is happening right
now oh my gosh it was it was jacob
gardner i just want to say that the man
who uh oh jailed himself yeah yeah we
talked about it oh that's right that's
right that's right yeah yeah he was the
guy who was in omaha yeah that's right
and they they attacked his restaurant
the guy was choking him out right
well
not only do we have those kind of
stories we also have this where at a
high school they're having minor males
give lap dances to okay that is so
unbelievable
no it's not come on i mean you're right
it's unbelievable but it's so the
audacity of these people first
they shut the schools down for over a
year and whine and complain anyone tells
them that they have to go back into the
classroom and do their job and then on
top of that they happen to be pushing
all this crt stuff this sort of
keynesian perverse sexual education
curriculum with all of these gross
modern ideas in it and then before this
story breaks we're seeing think pieces
about how parents don't really have
rights we need to allow the teachers to
do their jobs the attorney general
saying that as well the attorney general
today affirmed that he was going to
continue the investigation into angry
parents that's when the national school
boards association has uh basically
rescinded their original letter from
september that's what they need to be
investigating of course not the rampant
sex abuse problem in public schools it's
also not as if this is an isolated
occurrence you see sexual abuse is a
common phenomenon in public schools
this is this is just a practical right
this is like just the practical from the
gender queer health class exactly did
you see that book that was going viral
today we're weird foreign yeah yeah
where where it shows the president
touted this book it is disgusting if you
look at
in
adult activities yeah yep so this this
stuff is unbelievably disgusting i did a
video a couple weeks ago that i spent a
long time researching and it's about a
gentleman named kinsey by the name of
kinsey um yeah and
he is known as the father of sexology dr
kinsey he
basically was in high school their dog
was named kinsey oh wow yeah i know he
did like shame the guy i hope so no it
was it was just they thought it was
funny i mean a lot of people name their
dog sheamus it's a very common thing
when i say my name is shameless
anyway yeah so so kinsey
is basically the person who he is the
sexology what freud was to psychology i
mean he basically developed this field
and his accolades went on to develop
cecus which sets standards basically and
largely influences federal standards for
sexual education or what we call
comprehensive sexual education in the
united states so kinsey this is all the
way back in the 40s right he was doing
these surveys on human sexuality and he
published a document saying hey
what we learned from our surveys is that
people are not following the sexual
morals and norms that society has
attempted to foist upon them now his
findings were faulty and abraham maslow
who was by no means a religious
conservative came forward and said this
study was horribly done because he
oversampled prisoners homosexuals
prostitutes and it was also
self-reported that was the thing maslow
had the problem with that was
self-reported who in the 40s is going to
tell you their sexual history
of sex practices exactly
and so on top of that there were also
there was um
the official story from the kinsey
institute and they've changed their
story but the official story is that
there was a child sex abuser who came to
kinsey who kinsey taught how to use a
stopwatch to time his sexual abuse of
the children so that he could publish in
his documents and in the kinsey mail
report there is a data table showing
data i'll put it this way so i don't get
your channel deleted that you could only
possibly have if you sexually abuse the
child to get it so and so this is the
guy who's upon which we have based the
field of sexology and his disciples went
on to fonsecas and
it's all done with the assumptions that
he forwarded in our culture and the guy
was a pervert who was enabling
pedophiles
well we're still enabling pedophilia and
we're still enabling pedophiles but my
point is i mean here it is here it is in
kentucky well but that's my point people
see things like this in they think it
just started but the seeds were sown for
this a very long time ago you had in the
uh 1980s in time magazine pomeroy one of
kinsey's co-authors saying that he
thought that incestuous behavior between
adults and children is not necessarily
harmful i'm just on record wow
yikes just on record so this is what
we're starting to see translating to
these schools exactly that's that's how
it kind of comes together for people
exactly i mean you build your house on
sand it falls apart right and if your
house is built upon these horrific
immoral sexual attitudes you get
horrific immoral sexual outcomes yeah
and that includes sexual abuse it's
funny because it feels like
conservatives have been asleep at the
wheel for a long time very long time
democrats have mastered their ground
game they've really dominated for a long
time but the the democrats are in charge
of corporations they're in charge of um
political power they have all the
cultural power they have the academic
and institutional power
so they have control over all of these
avenues of power in the united states
and they're using it to bludgeon the
rest of us
and they're acting as though they are
speaking out against power because
that's the language that they have used
to gain power we're speaking against
this
overarching authoritarian you know
totalitarian moral code and now they're
using those exact same tactics to
destroy us amen on purpose well because
all along to them power was just
new speak for thing we don't like right
because it's blatantly obvious that
they're the people in power so whenever
they say your publication attacks
the downtrodden and you punch down they
say this about humor they dislike all
the time it's punching down people are
punching everything right exactly what
they mean by down is thing we like
doesn't matter whether that thing is
empowered or not
what matters is they like it so they say
it's it's powerless or it represents the
powerless but it has nothing to do with
actual power dynamics it just happens to
be something that they like and so
they know it's it's better optics
the seat of power is corporations yeah
corporations and we're seeing that so
fully we see that online all the time
you know like the corporations do what
they're told that's how it appears
um and then they take all of that and
they forced it on the rest of us i was i
was looking up um
diversity officer it's just as
impressive as as the religious
authorities used to be mm-hmm i would
say that it's worse i would say more
more
way worse you like religion deeply
influential in a lot of ways but when i
was growing up nowhere near the power of
massive corporations no but the flesh
told us that they had that kind of power
the left told us that this moral
authority was bad and that we needed to
fight against it and it was really just
people voting together well and you know
why because and it was communities it
was communities helping each other evil
always calls for tolerance and then when
it's ascendant it calls for compliance
and that's exactly what we're seeing yep
yep
and uh
you know well it's interesting when you
look at these corporations oftentimes
they'll make decisions about who they
should hire or fire
what kinds of and what i mean who they
should hire fire i mean in mass like
what you know number of minorities do we
need at this company do we need to hire
more women of color more transgender
people etc should we apologize for this
commercial should we try to
bring more diversity etc they make
decisions like this on the basis of a
small handful of people
at twitter tweeting at them because they
think that means there is a large number
of people or a large majority of people
out there who are going to boycott them
if they don't obey right so one of their
employees does something wrong and then
a couple people tweet at them they lose
their minds because the quote-unquote
consensus on twitter's one way but
what's really important i just want to
say one more thing according to a pew
survey
twitter users are plus 15 democrats so
it would be
one of the most democratic states in the
country and that's basically what
they're doing you wouldn't quite call it
market research but that's where they're
getting a lot of their data on what the
american people want i looked up chief
diversity officer yeah that's a new
thing it sure is and uh wikipedia's
first entry goes back to 2008.
and uh if you look up ceo it goes back
to 2002 obviously because ceo's been
around for a long time diversity officer
is basically communist party member
right so the chinese communist party has
amen they have their party member in all
these businesses that assert authority
and control over how you fall in line
now what they're starting to do is
they're starting to make chief diversity
officers and it is the most insane thing
you can ever imagine
like it's like a tumor because think
about it
what does a chief executive officer do i
mean they run the show they they make
executive decisions right on everything
now the chief operating officer executes
on those things he's in charge of the
advantage of the data they did
everything runs the operations then you
have chief marketing officer head of
marketing chief technology officer then
you have like content officers you have
high ranking positions based around
specific tasks for companies
what would so so content chief content
officer we know what that does they they
manage overseas content what is content
well it's the thing you're making and
selling chief marketing officer they're
selling the product to everybody chief
operating officers running the company
they're doing things that make money
that matter chief diversity officer the
chief proselytizing
ideology diversity and the chief
diversity officer has to make sure that
racism remains front and form based in
the company you have to make sure that
there's constantly racism problems in
the company otherwise you have no job
yes there's no point of the chief
diversity officer other than maintaining
their position yes and that's exactly
this is why it's making human resources
a bigger department yeah well this is
why thomas soul said never put activists
in charge of solving a problem of course
the activist has nothing to do with the
problems
they're going to find things that seem
problematic when they aren't because
that's their bread and butter i learned
this uh when i worked for these
non-profits
a good non-profit puts itself out of
business hey here's a problem we want to
solve a problem we made it made a bunch
of money we campaigned for problem
problem is solved goodbye everybody have
a nice day they never never ever well
once i think it was clear a couple of
years ago when they um investigations
started into these not-for-profits they
were like the
was it the
the
race for the cure whatever that one was
the pink ribbon yeah it turned out that
some massive amount 95 90.
of the revenue went to
further the operation itself not to do
anything
yeah that's something so it was all for
administrative costs right so it wasn't
to further the mission it was to
maintain the company it's supposed to be
like a good non-profit is 90 charitable
10 costs i think it's fair to say
because i've worked for some non-profits
where it's like 50 50 and you're like
well look if paying the salaries of
people running the company
is consuming amount of resources
and it's high i still think it's fine if
it's 95 to five
especially for a very large non-profit
or the executive director is getting
paid millions of dollars exactly i mean
it's thinkable that in certain
circumstances based on the kind of
activism they're engaged in it might be
more complicated so the administrative
costs might be higher but 95 is absurd
it's really just all about the gala
so that everyone feels good yeah it goes
back to those celebs giving themselves
awards again that's what it's all about
that's what exactly
big ol circle and then
these are the tax breaks and then these
are the tax breaks that are taken by the
big multi-billion dollar corporations
that elizabeth warren wants to pay their
fair share but they're giving all their
money to the gala it's it's it's not so
easy you know i'm learning this
especially people think that a lot of
these ultra wealthy individuals
will
start a non-profit and just hide their
money or an llc it's not that easy to do
but they find these work arounds where
they can do certain things there's
there's seems like i know it's not easy
i've looked into it
well no because we're doing two
non-profits yeah yeah no i know i'm on
the board of one of them right oh that's
uh and so i'm talking to the our
accountant about like okay so i want to
get this ball rolling on truth and media
we want to start fact checking what can
we do like how much can we do and
they're like here's your limit you can
only do so much you'll need to find
other donors and i was like oh wow all
right well interesting there you go yeah
so it's not it's not like you can just
hide all your money or write it all off
but there's there are things that these
companies do
where it's like you'll create 10
non-profits and then they have the money
as like a whirlpool shuffling around
which basically cleans them of tax
liability and things like that so it's
like if you got 10 non-profits then you
can donate a little bit to each one then
they can all donate to one then you can
pay yourself a 10 million dollar salary
so there was also crazy things when i
was doing when i was doing theater arts
um because
one of the things people would do is
start their own theater company right so
that they could do their own work which
i did that too but other people got they
created not-for-profits out of their
theater companies so that they were
charitable organizations when it was
really just like a couple of people from
barnard or whatever who wanted to do
theater projects and then they would get
all of their families to donate and
their families companies to donate so
that all of this money would just pour
in
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
p.m and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you